who'sa is not just about scooping ice
cream into a cup and eating it there's
also the theatrical aspect and and
creating that experience for the
customer to see we do it at the start of
the day throughout the day and I'd be
lying if I said it wasn't tough but
really every customer deserves and means
the full buuza experience sometimes it's
fast sometimes it's slow and sometimes
you have no idea what you're gonna get
but ultimately it all works out in the
end my name is Jill barrels mita my name
is Michael Sadler and we make 500 pounds
of booze a day we get in about 7 a.m.
and first thing that we do out in front
is get everything ready for service for
the day who'sa is the original form of
ice cream that was first developed about
500 years ago in the eastern part of the
Mediterranean and it's distinguished
from other forms of ice cream by a soft
elastic light consistency we have 17
flavors at any one time on rotation and
they split out across classic global and
experimental flavor categories so that
means there's a lot of stuff we need to
do before the doors open for customers a
lot of work to be done a lot of loser to
be made in a in a very short period of
time
so once we receive the milk delivery we
normally take things straight into the
back and Boozer starts with the base and
milk and cream obviously form a very
large percentage of the product follow
after that by obviously sugar everyone's
favorite sweetener and a little bit of
skim milk powder because it helps with
the mouthfeel of the actual end product
using a specific type of milk and a
specific type of cream means we don't
have to use as much sugar just due to
the natural sweetness that we get from
the actual milk itself now we pasteurize
because we think that's the best way to
get a great product starting from
scratch with pure ingredients once we
start the pasteurization process we
normally take the product to about 155
degrees Fahrenheit and hold it there for
30 minutes we then bring it back down to
refrigeration temperature whose is very
similar to conventional forms of ice
cream but instead of using egg yolks or
cornstarch it uses two ancient
all-natural plant-based ingredients
known as sahaba and mastic sahab is a
flour traditionally made from ground-up
orchid root and mastic is a resin that
comes by sun drying the sap of a tree in
greece together the two ingredients
contain the elastic potential holes that
you see with the product yesterday I
started soaking some true for nuts and
they will go into our horchata base
along with a little bit of the sugar and
cinnamon and then we'll also be
preparing some of the the bark that we
put into the UH peanut butter crunch
which is some lightly salted potato
chips along with a blend of milk and
white chocolate we let that set and then
we chopped that up into lots of little
pieces they get thrown into the me
I'll prepare some of the vanilla so
we're using the halala vanilla beans
that come straight from Tonga for about
a two kilogram bucket you're talking
about $3,000 and that's what it costs
but adds a great floral note to the
flavor of our vanilla and now that the
products been prepared it's time to
actually turn it
so we use a freezer drum here that has
refrigeration coils what we do is we
pour in the base into there and
essentially splash the base onto the
side so can actually freeze we scrape it
down the sides and reintegrate the
frozen product into the non frozen
product is quite a labor-intensive
process splashing it against the sides
it helps us get it to the right texture
and consistency it can just sit there
and freeze over neither you end up with
a hard rock once we've done scraping
down the sides and and Boozer has
reached a specific consistency that's
when we start to use the wooden pestle
but I'm doing this it kind of feels like
being part of an improv that everyone
brings a different Pacey who's is doing
something the pestles doing something
I'm doing something and we're all
working in unison to ultimately come up
with this amazing symphony of
Awesomeness and flavor because it's made
by hand it's impossible to predict the
texture at any one point in time there's
no fixed formula and we like saying it's
more of an art than a science because it
has to be done by feel they're really
getting it to that money stage where you
can see that extremely elastic visual
and get the full wingspan is the result
of a constant back and forth balancing
it's almost like sex sometimes it's fast
sometimes it's slow and sometimes you
have no idea what you're gonna get but
ultimately it all works out in the end
[Music]
the first customer for the day sets the
tone for the day we're always thinking
about how to improve all the customer
experience more friendly more accessible
to present our product in the best way
possible to everything that we've been
thinking about for the last 24 hours
first comes into play when that first
customer comes in the door get to taste
as many flavors as possible hopefully
pick a flavor that works for them or
hopefully discover something new that
they've never tried before Boozer is not
just about scooping ice cream into a cup
and eating it there's also the
theatrical aspect and and creating that
experience for the customer to see
[Music]
we love when we see excitement and
customers faces return to that childhood
level or a state of excitement at going
to the ice cream shop ice cream is
nostalgic for many many people around
the world there's a lot of happy
memories around that and I think happy
memories give us a great opportunity to
have classic flavors to help people kind
of step in the door and know the
familiar but also have other things like
global and experimental things that
they've never tried and weren't really
aware you could actually put into
something like bozer and actually
deliver an amazing product at the end of
the afternoon we'll see a whole and foot
traffic and in customers today's an are
indeed day so we're gonna find it some
new things to play around with
experimenting is a huge thing for us
that we do today Mike and I are planning
to go visit a log supermarket and seeing
how we're gonna integrate that into one
of our newest flavors
[Music]
or on the red side yeah here we go
definitely make sure we get the whole
one
I'll focus on some seasonal ingredients
today we're thinking of introducing a
new sorbet flavor and bring together a
few ingredients and see if they work
together we're going to take a few
different directions with what we try
from the flavor combination perspective
to try to probably try something with
potentially with dairy something without
a little bit of dairy is it perfect
every time probably not
sometimes when you step out of your
comfort zone though you come up with
something truly amazing
[Music]
alright so things can sometimes get a
little bit crazy so as we're actually
making always our from scratch the team
are also serving customers and we're
also interacting with customers and
talking to them about the process it's
very interactive but obviously as you
can imagine it's quite intense part of
our daily routines are consist of
agitating the the buuza manually in the
display case we do it at the start of
the day throughout the day and even
every time before we serve a customer
and even a sample you'll see staff to
give the light little swirl activates
the elastic potential of the Safa band
the mastic and really makes sure that
every mouthful is superlatively smooth
and when it gets busy it can become easy
to lose focus but really every customer
deserves and needs the full bruza
experience
and I focus on the quality of the
product the quality of the experience it
makes us feel a sense of accomplishment
at having achieved our goal
[Music]
the store closes at midnight
usually we begin the cleanup and closing
routine around 12:15 12:30 we love ice
cream
we love buuza but I'd be lying if I said
it wasn't tough you know Manning the
day-to-day getting home at 1:00 a.m.
sometimes later but ultimately you know
feeling like I'm a part of building
something Republic of buuza is centered
around bringing people together and
introducing them to all sorts of new
flavors and tastes and it gives me that
extra kick to keep going every day today
we made 500 pounds of booze oh and
tomorrow we're gonna do it all over
again
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]